thank you very much thanks for the rim
shot there jared appreciate that all
right happy wednesday everybody we've
got a beautiful sunrise out there and
you can see the palm trees out on the
west side from the red rock casino
resort camera up on the rooftop if you
ever drive by on the 215 or if you're in
the area
of the red rock resort look way up on
the roof and you'll see that one little
palm tree there's actually two they're
kind of spread apart this is the one we
show you all the time up there on the
roof in our camera and you can see the
city way out here it's beautiful sun is
on the rise and we've got some north
breezes and that's making it feel just a
little bit extra chilly so grab a coat
or a jacket sweater or something to keep
you warm temperatures are cooler some
neighborhoods almost 10 degrees cooler
than yesterday yesterday we had the
clouds so we had 60s everywhere this
morning we're down in the 50s centennial
hills 57 summerlin out near the red rock
casino resort 56 55 mountains edge seven
hills you're in the mid 50s too 59 in
henderson right now and 57 at the
airport so it is cool and it's been
extra breezy in the mountains let's
start up in western nevada reno back
into the 30s tone paw you're there as
well
ealy's back down to the 20s skipping
over to southwest utah look at those
chilly 30's for cedar city lincoln
county just north of us up in clark here
in clark county lincoln county in the
30's indian springs in the 40's perump
in the 40's and laflin checking in at 60
degrees boulder city you're in the 50's
so as we look around the intermountain
west state pretty chilly but outside
la's at 60 phoenix 58 not bad more
showers for the pacific northwest for
seattle and portland we'll get some rain
showers today and there is definitely
some colder air on the way with rain
across the northern plains turning into
snow getting up into
minnesota minneapolis at 41 will be
looking for some rain and cooler weather
by tonight 58 degrees in kansas city and
milder temps across the eastern u.s 66
in washington d.c
and again the tomb of the unknowns
welcoming visitors for the first time in
a century people can actually place
flowers we'll talk more about that in
the next half hour clouds are headed for
the east coast and there is a spacex
rocket shuttle for nasa carrying a nasa
crew up to the international space
station that launches tonight that will
be 605 hour time and so far there are
some showers this morning passing very
close
and we'll see it's about an 80 percent
chance of good weather tonight for the
launch it's already been postponed since
halloween night so here's the jet stream
carrying more inclement weather up in
the pacific northwest but for us nice
sunshine today some north breezes mid
70s the air is going to be extra clean
beautiful veterans day tomorrow sunny
skies and mid to upper 70s then we're on
our way back up to near 80 degrees for
the weekend next week we'll cool down a
little bit get some clouds coming and
going